I want you to cast your mind back for a
bit
[Music]
no no way too far it's summer holiday in
eighth grade and you've just discovered
anime Mirai Nikki is close to Peak
akamega kill was the most tragic thing
you'd ever seen that scene where Kirito
gets his second sword and shouts out
Starburst or streamer what's the goddamn
coolest thing you'd ever seen because of
course it was you were 13 everything was
cool you didn't care about character
development you didn't think about story
structure you heard a quote like I'm a
gamer not because I don't have a life
but because sorry but because I choose
to have many and you thought to yourself
down that's deep I'm a gamer will you
cringe hell yeah you were but you know
what you enjoyed yourself and that's
what's important even if you could look
back and think God what was I thinking
but what happens when you find a show
that stops trying to run away from that
cringe it Embraces the cringe distills
the cringe Knuckles down and envelops
you in the edge Fest high intensity
full-blown world of cringe you thought
you'd grown past and refuses to
apologize about it I need more
he got the Eminence in Shadow anime has
been absolutely killing it lately 2022
was not only full of surprises but shows
that pushed the boundary of anime modern
Classics that stamps their mark on the
scene and will stick with us for years
to come Eminence and Shadow it's not one
of those shows this is every 14 year old
teenage angsty fantasy turn up to 11.
it's edgy it's horny it might well just
be the new king of trashy isakai and is
by far the most goddamn fun I've had in
the genre for years re-zero slime
mushoka tensei all brilliant shows we've
gotten in the past few years that absorb
you into that intricate world and have
shown us how truly great isekai can be
if these three shows are the three star
Michelin mules of isakai this is
Eminence and Shadow and this is me
okay
but how did Eminence and Shadow get me
to embrace the cringe giggle do you
fantasize about getting hit by a truck
is this another case of me having isakai
brain rot no okay I haven't forgotten
what good anime is I still remember my
best of 2022 anime list I still remember
chainsaw man speaking of which chainsaw
man itself is having a collaboration
with today's sponsor
that's right this video is sponsored by
Nikkei and we're working with them this
month to let you all know about the
hottest crossover this year as Nikkei
and Chainsaw man are working together
for the first time that's right chainsaw
man's most popular female characters are
joining the Nikkei roster Nikkei is an
immersive sci-fi RPG featuring casual
arcade shooter gameplay and you can now
recruit power himeno and most
importantly makima to join your ultimate
gun-wielding waifu team the girls in
Tokyo division 4 have been seen in
nikkei's World Through The Gatekeepers
dreams which is very fitting as Mark
Mayer's crept into my dreams more than
just a few times these last few months
Nikkei has given makima power and himeno
their own newly designed unique weapons
that are different from the anime itself
not only that but during battle you'll
be able to witness their elaborate skill
Cuts closely duplicated from chainsaw
man to a level never before seen in the
game prior to this collaboration that's
not all though as Nikkei itself now has
a PC version available so you can play
on a larger screen for more immersive
gameplay as well as new adapted controls
for a more traditional mouse and
keyboard shooting experience of course
there's cross-platform support between
PC and mobile for access to convenient
idle gameplay freeing up your phone to
scroll through pictures of markima while
you play Nikkei so what are you waiting
for head to the link in the description
to download the game today to experience
the Nikkei and Chainsaw man
collaboration in all its Glory thank you
to Nikkei for sponsoring me today and
back to the video I know what you're
thinking but look it's been one whole
year since my last isakai video on this
channel and the tax has to be paid white
girls have True Crime gigak has [__]
isakai but contrary to popular belief I
don't just blindly recommend every trash
Isa car that airs every season and
before you go yo that's cap this is my
face when I'm saying it look at this
serious face do you see how deathly
serious I am taking this I would never
mislead you on something like this
this is a show that won't go down as a
classic of anime it doesn't have a lot
in common with the isakai greats like
Michelle kotensei Eminence and Shadow is
edgy self-surfing you see what happens
in it and it's like
whilst the Michelle kotensei is more
like the plot goes like this said kagano
is a man obsessed with but unfortunately
he gets hit by a truck and dies reborn
in a fantasy world he continues
I give up the big issue I've had when
trying to talk about the show to anyone
is that as soon as I open my mouth to
explain anything that happens I
instantly lose anyone listening because
everything that comes out of my mouth
sounds [__] stupid because it is
[__] stupid the main point of this
show is that Sid makes up the most dumb
convoluted fanfiction.net tumblrass plot
developments he can think up on the spot
and it turns out to be true the man has
no investment in the people around him
and what's going on he's just
role-playing his perfect isekai power
fantasy story and everyone in the world
is forced to dance to his tune on one
side he's Shadow incarnation of
Vengeance entity of the night Slayer of
[__] the man [__] without losing his
virginity because he never loses Shadow
is a man who based their entire
personality over listening to Mike
Chemical Romance once this is what
people who shop to Hot Topics are in
their mind's eye shadow is the type of
guy who would say you know what they
call it the Dead Sea why
because I killed it
but on the flip side he's playing old
Sid kagano a guy devoted to being an
invisible background character who won't
stand out won't attract attention
chasing his dream to be the ultimate
real-life NPC which hey guys I'm in New
York City just hanging out
honestly it's not hard to do nowadays
the thing is he will refuse to break
character no matter what and I really
mean no matter what his sister gets
kidnapped and tortured his school is the
target of a terrorist attack there are
classmates getting murdered around him
left and right and the first thing that
goes through his mind is or our boys
it's NPC time how can I give myself the
most pathetic death possible as Shadow
he will literally commit to robbing a
grand piano only to transport it to an
underground cave so he can ominously
play it with the lights beaming down for
the Ultimate Edge Lord look
the mad is more dedicated to his role
Than Jake Paul is to playing an [__]
he could give Daniel Day-Lewis a run for
his money in his commitment to method
acting oh okay so this is like a parody
of Easter guy kinda comedy is subjective
it's a phrase people use when they're
about to say they don't find something
funny Eminence the shadow has some
decent jokes here and there though it
can be hit or miss sometimes it'll do
this thing where it will spell out this
overused Trope and pass it off as a joke
which is something I've always despised
but sometimes it can play around with
our expectations in amusing ways we've
all watched that scene where the main
character accidentally goes in the hot
spring sees the girl she goes
gets angry blah blah blah all right
here's what happens with Sid barges into
hot spring it's the girl's hot spring
doesn't acknowledge the girl flexes his
pee pee refuses to elaborate further
this is a show that is not afraid to
play around with tropes we're familiar
with and subvert our expectations to
varying degrees of success but what I
found more impressive and a hell of a
lot more amusing is how hard it commits
to its own [__] act it makes fun of
itself while doubling down tripling down
quadrupling the [__] down on all the
cheesy cringe ass moments we roll our
eyes at in your typical trashy power
fantasy isakai Beyond being a straight
up parody it's just entirely self-aware
if you find yourself not taking the show
too seriously then end up being
completely invested in all the dumb [__]
that ends up happening they say that
love and hate are two halves of the same
coin but Eminence and Shadow proves that
the exact same thing is true with cringe
and cool because what happens when you
take all those cringe scenes that would
only appeal to an edgy 13 year old
distill it rev up the stupidity to 100
does it somehow become cool again this
is what Eminence and Shadow asks and I
think there's one scene that
encapsulates everything the show is
about so if you don't want to be spoiled
for episode 5 just skip ahead Sid has
always been obsessed of becoming
powerful in his past life he was already
pretty op the man dedicated himself to
being Batman without all the fancy
gadgets he had trained enough to take
down any Thug he encountered but so what
no matter how much a mortal can train
there are still limits to what you can
achieve what if he went up against a
firing squad what if someone dropped a
nuclear bomb on you no matter how much
you develop your muscles hone your mind
perfected your skills if someone comes
along with a nuclear bomb you'd be
instantly vaporized or so he thought
because reincarnated in a new world he
refused to give up on his dream there
was still a height he had yet to attain
so after years upon years of training he
arrived at but a single Solution that's
right if I don't want to be vaporized by
a nuclear explosion I must simply become
the nuke
I
am
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this fully commits to being the power
fantasy isekai then goes 10 steps
further beyond what is necessary he is
stupidly op he's never in any real
danger he'll say cringe lines and pass
them off as the coolest thing ever said
you think other Easter car protagonists
specialize in having their own Harem
well not only does every influential
figure happen to be a cute girl who of
course ends up falling for him but he's
got down built an entire Shadow
organization with zero boys allowed
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon Ada Zeta
Sigma the man's created his own Harem
Institute of hundreds not dozens
hundreds of super powered waifus that
end up amassing so much wealth and power
that they end up influencing the world
stage and he did this by complete
accident but the best part of all this
is having to see everyone in the world
take Sid's [__] role-playing 100
seriously this is a fully functioning
fantasy land with Nations vying for
power secret organizations manipulating
the global politics characters are in a
life or death struggle to defend the
Homeland they so love and then Along
Comes This dude countries pour their
resources into figuring out what exactly
is Shadow Garden who's in it what they
want what are their goals and
motivations how does their presence
affect the world and meanwhile Sid's
just there like he should immense a
power everyone is playing Game of
Thrones while Sid is playing Dungeons
and Dragons except hears every dungeon
Master's worst nightmare someone who
just makes [__] up as he goes along
breaks every rule of the game ignores
the Big Shiny thing that is shouting
this is the plot but is incapable of
rolling anything but not 20. and so
everything he ends up doing has real
consequences to the world around him a
lot of people have compared this to
overlords but I think this is actually
closer to isakai one punch man and I'm
gonna be honest part of the reason I'm
making this video is because I'm praying
that this doesn't stop at just two
seasons yeah yeah I'm excited to get
more of the East Kai greats but for the
love of God give me five more double Big
Mac Meals of this please Eminence and
Shadow is a series is that should not
work but somehow it does this is what
happens when every single person working
on an anime absolutely understands the
assignment it's a series which gives
absolutely zero [__] in being cringy
edgy or childish it is a man who larps
so hard it became reality but the more
you watch the more you get sold in his
[__] it throws at you every Trope
every cliche every eye rolling corny
line you've ever heard in your life and
you end up eating that [__] up like it's
the first time you've ever seen an anime
this is what happens when you reach the
peak of trashy entertaining isekai and I
don't know what more I can do to reach
even greater Heights I don't want to be
the last boss
the one in the story who operates from
the Shadows
the imminence and Shadow okay now it's
perfect
hey God
what the [__] was that hey guys hope you
enjoyed that video thank you very much
this month to Alpha Sigma author Curtis
Eckstein basil dysfunctional degenerate
flabber walking ivito lovados
mikasa12315 Payne patches Pony Stark
Water Guys VT and everyone else my
patreon for helping support me for this
month and making this video possible yes
guys it had to happen again you knew I
needed to pay the yearly isakai attacks
and you know what more perfect season to
catch up with all the isakai than this
winter season which uh I gotta be honest
is a little bit slower than full but hey
I'm not complaining at least I get to
catch up with all the anime that I
wanted to if you ask me why I didn't
watch Full Metal Alchemist I'm Banning
you from the channel anyway though guys
that's it from me today no further
updates I've been gigock and I'll see
you all next time